الذي - التي
[موسيقى]
حظر في صنعاء كان قال بان وآخرون لوار
تحطم تيبي مين لكاتين الروك فرنسا ذلك
هناك 4 في جميع أنحاء العالم تبدأ من الكاتو
أنيما بن عياد يتغلب على شارلي واتس
الآرياس الإماراتي صحيح علينا ذلك
للتكيف مع المنحدرات شديدة الانحدار
نقوم بتحويل الطبيعة قليلاً إلى
نصنع شرفات لكننا نطمئن أنفسنا
بالقول لأنفسنا لقد لمسنا الطبيعة ولكن
ليس لدينا في سيدة لكل هذا الخير
الأرض لا تنتمي إلينا نمر
نحن نمر فقط وواجب
إرسال في أفضل حالة
ممكن
إذن هذا هو معنى مهنة الفلاح
صانعي النبيذ العام ليس لديهم
yotaro michel أو جذب سوريا إليه
يكرر حتى الفلاحي عالم فيه
لاتينا زوجة نخب آني amouriq
Isère لقد تسابق في العالم و
يتفاعل البحرية ولفة تواجهنا
لاحظ الحجة الرئيسية التي بنيت في الوسط
الأميري آلام أودين حتى الشباب
عندما يعملون هناك يكون الأمر أكثر من أي شيء آخر
قاسية نحن
لكنهم يقولون ذلك في الحد الأقصى
في بعض الأحيان أقل تعبا في هذه المؤامرة
حيث يبدو أنه قريب بعض الشيء
من السماء أشاد الشاب ثيو إلى إيفان
بودارت الأنياب جيلدان باردي
Mazeyrat riabinin بواسطة الميكافيلي ATI
سلسلة alliot-marie penknife سوف تموت
لكن بعد ذلك صحيح أن كريستين
مايلسي السيدة تشاو بالتأكيد هناك القليل
اكتئاب
عليك القيام بذلك بشكل صحيح والاستمرار في القيام به
احتفظ بالصورة التي قاموا بإنشائها وبعدها
ربما بأسلوب مختلف قليلاً
ربما استمتع بأشياء أخرى
بهدف أن لدينا حاوية صغيرة
يمكننا قضاء وقت ممتع هنا يريد أن يأخذ
المزيد من المخاطرة بفعل الآخرين
لقاءات خلال كل شيء تغير كل شيء
ثورة
كما ينبغي أن تكون لغة الباسك وللفريق
الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية الخفافيش ديموغرافيات الكلب إيلينا
ميشيل نحن ذاهبون إلى عائلة غوتشي في
عائلة كلود شام وهو الخزاف في
عظام في القرية بما في ذلك 16 حتى هو
الفخار الذي تديره عائلة مع أ
خبرة استثنائية
الفنلندية الفحم tcmt البندق إيرما
نوالحات وحشد ميشال مسكتك
منحرف - مائل
هنا الآخر هو الجيل الآخر
الفنانة أيضا ها هو الطفل نحن
فعلنا معا هنا رسمنا
لذلك نضعهم في عالم الخمر
ساعدناهم في اتخاذ هذه الخطوة و
بومباي المغامرة تواصل التقيت ndo
ليون الذي ولد قبل 35 عامًا هو أ
مغامرة تقنية رائعة
مغامرة عاطفية ونحن اليوم
سيكون لدينا حوالي ثلاثين من مزارعي النبيذ
يعمل بشكل قوي وهو
تقنية بارعة جدا
يجعل من الممكن صنع أحجام كبيرة من
الفخار دفعة واحدة
إنه الحبل الذي سيمسك الطين
ناعم جدا منك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
التونة مدينة أفيرا مندأرتس
جنب هارونا باري دينين لفيف الهلال
ربثالي لانوي للبيسبول والاخت
والطبقة و eisenach المناجم الرهيبة
مدينتي جلاديه الآن لست متأكدا
أجهزة الراديو كانو ألبا كروم ساتان أسود
اجلس فيه بينما أنت
كل الرادار المأمون بوردة نصيبي
RAF Right Attack ولا من فرنسا
Badaroux في الحب مثل البحرية في
صنعاء في الشتاء كان الجو باردا جدا
وعلى التلفزيون في الراديو قال
عليك أن تطعم الطيور
والآباء لم يعرفوا ماذا يفعلون
وقد ذهب إلى الجزار الذي كان معه
أخذ بعض زركشة لحم البقر وفي
مقطعة إلى نرد صغير
طرحنا ذلك على المرمى
تأتي طيور رينيس وتأكله
سعيد ومثلما قاله الناس
بعد أن سألوا بالما كاناريس مرة أخرى
جزر البهاما وتضحك على المبنى و
البادئ للمواد المبتكرة و
قاد ماتا mindef جانوت فيفياني
إذا كنت هنا فذلك لأننا
كنا 2 عملنا في 2 هناك
ليس أنا فقط ولكن كلاهما
وكلا منا كان صعبًا
هنا وأنا المطبخ
عندما توماس لي غرقت بجانبها
جلبت لي علي أحمد نافيد الباب الخلفي من نحن
رفعت الخرشنة المقود إشعار العربة
الفيلم لم يتوقف عن الاستمتاع به
قاسية جدا تتطلب عملا جيدا
ولذا فهي المرحلات قليلاً
هنا محليًا أيضًا أنهم يلعبون
اللعبة وبعد ذلك أعتقد والنبيذ
مع من يمكن أن يتماشى مع
السمك والطبخ على وجه التحديد
مبروك المحلية وبرافو سيدتي
ميلو ولكن تشارلز في القديس مارتن
خاضت viviane مثل منارة في sacem
أو عائلتي عبلاي شيلين في صنعاء
صنع لي من قبل كاتيل براسك البرج ليقول
لأشياء ضياء طويل الشيخ فاتي ماديرا
خرج الجميع للجلوس في لا إله إلا
لم يزعج الموهبة